the countdown to christmas is on if you
need help like many of us do our friends
at the grand canal shops at the venetian
resort are here to help i'm joined by
their senior marketing manager janet
lefevre thank you for joining us today
happy holidays happy holidays to you it
is a busy time over there but it is one
of my favorite places to go for the
holidays with the shops the food the
decor let's talk a little bit about
last minute gifts what are some of the
stores that we can go to over at the
grand canal shops absolutely well one of
the great little secrets about grand
canal shops is we're open on christmas
day
so we see many men that come down last
minute shopping which is all good but if
you also need that last minute hostess
gift we have incredible selections no
passport required things from spirits
and spice which is an exclusive lacour
company
royce chocolates from japan which is a
great hostess gift or our newest
menswear collection which is shinobi
menswear with incredible curated brands
that can't be found anywhere else in the
united states brand new to grand canal
shops i i couldn't help but notice uh
one of my favorite places to go at the
grand canal shops you're wearing some
flats from tory burch i love to get
their jewelry oh that's that's another
great place for the ladies absolutely
there's just a plethora of gift giving
at grand canal everything from you know
daughters and moms from tory burch which
is incredible to our new louis vuitton
that just expanded burberry salvador
ferragamo mont blanc but then there's
really other lux and accessible stores
as well right there's nectar bath treats
and then we have an incredible selection
of dining if you just want to come down
and enjoy our holiday show have a
cocktail really everything for shopping
dining and last minute gift giving is so
accessible at grand canal shops i was
going to mention that i know a lot of
families for christmas instead of
cooking the traditional dinner they like
to make it a day where they all go out
can you tell us about some of the
restaurants that you have over at the
grand canal shop we have an incredible
we have dozens of you know celebrity
chef driven restaurants sushi samba our
brand new the xpot which is traditional
chinese hot pot at a very elevated
luxurious level is just really doing
incredibly well and a unique offering
and of course there's traditional
favorites like smith and malinsky which
has an incredible menu for the holidays
tau asian bistro and of course cut by
wolfgang puck
the list goes on and on and there's just
really something for everyone from steak
to asian to also of course italian make
sure you make those reservations though
to get in there because uh they will be
going past so many great restaurants and
before we wrap up i just want to remind
everyone and you mentioned this at the
beginning the decor it is it is the
holidays there it is so fun i'm taking
my family tomorrow we're going to just
go walk around do some last minute
shopping and that's something you can
experience over at the grand canal shops
we're so looking forward to checking it
out absolutely we would love to have
everyone it's just the most perfect
family-friendly environment and of
course no passport needed to get any of
your global gifts there's free parking
and we're just right off the 15 at
spring mountains so very easy to get to
and to enjoy for everyone thank you so
much we appreciate it we're going to
send it over to you kendall all right
you